[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice i'm
dave ramsey your host this is the show
where we talk about your work
your relationships
your money and you dr john deloney joins
me as my co-host today as we talk about
your life the phone number is triple
eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in and we
will talk today is launch day this is
launch week at ramsey for the new book
baby steps millionaires congratulations
man well thank you sold a bajillion
copies so far yep congratulations thank
you folks out there i mean it's
it's sitting in the you know top 10 on
amazon right now and uh you know it'll
go on up probably the number one by the
end of the day i've been doing media
since 5 a.m and so it's uh but it's it's
uh our our marketing team our gr our
team here and our and our listeners our
tribe our group that follows us they
help out so much with this stuff and so
thank all of you very very much the book
is
worth every penny it'll show you exactly
how to get there
and i'm very proud of it i haven't done
a book in eight years but
this is airtight
it makes the case
if you pay the price you will get the
prize
and i can show you exactly how to do it
and if you want to argue with me your
what's known as wrong
i've got it i've got this i've got this
crap dialed in i can't work on your car
and i can't do brain surgery this i can
do i can show you how to be a
millionaire exactly how to do it and it
will take you 12 to 17 years you're not
going to hit the lottery and bitcoin's
not going to do it for you neither will
buying beanie babies or a lottery ticket
so you're going to have to actually do
the work and if you do the work the
probability of you making it to
millionaire status is right close to one
hundred percent that's incredible you
know it's so fun it's so cool i mean i'm
my where i mean when you plant corn
you're not even sure it's gonna grow
right you know i'm sure you're gonna get
corn so you know you just you just hope
it comes up this is just like you know
if some people have some uh things they
have to overcome
we all got obstacles we all got our
issues that's why you're here
and you know but i mean this is uh this
is so doable and i was talking on one of
the shows this morning uh with the lady
i said you know the thing you got to
remember is you know math is not racist
math is not sexist
math just and math works in california
and math works in new york and math
works in tennessee
and it all works exactly the same yeah
it and it's just it it is so stinking
predictable and we just make this air
airtight case to where the hope steelers
out there in our culture with all this
negative ninis out there running around
telling people they can't win you can't
have a good life your life sucks the
only way your life is going to be good
is if the government takes it over oh
please
really
when has that ever worked
instead we show you exactly what to do
and we take the hope stealers and we
toss them in the ditch
and you can go do this man i'm just
pumped because it's so hope-filled in a
culture and in
an environment that is so toxic right
now there's so much negative crap out
there yeah
and uh i and i don't know if it's gotten
worse or just the media is worth
telling us all day long with this steady
drum beat of manure
it's just piles of manure after piles i
can't watch it
you know it's just um
but somebody's got to stand up and go
you know what regular folk are out here
winning yeah
and we can show you how so that that's
exciting and baby steps millionaires you
can get it anywhere the great books are
sold including
ramseysolutions.com thursday night
rachel cruz george camel and i will be
doing building wealth 2022 over a
hundred thousand folks are already
signed up for the free live stream on
that 1600 bought the tickets up in just
a few minutes when we put it up for sale
for the live event itself and so it's
been sold out since we told people they
could do it and so we'll have 1600 folks
in the audience and then another hundred
thousand watching online uh there's
still room online
you you can still get in uh that room
won't sell out so
and the cost is yeah it's a good
internet joke thanks abe lincoln said
that yeah and so um the uh
the cost is uh is where you can even do
it building wealth in 2022 and it's
completely free to watch it uh it's this
coming thursday night go to
ramseysolutions.com
wealth and get signed up for that it has
just been a great day a great week
around here really really exciting
congratulations man you put the
finishing touches on yours it's gone to
the printer it is it is out of my hands
so we're going to be uh uh announcing a
new full-on
major trade publication by dr john
dolone in the next few weeks we'll be
telling you about that
that'll be the next uh publishing effort
to come out of ramsey press in the
spring here we'll let you guys know the
details on that when we're ready to uh
let the uh proverbial cat out of the bag
but it's uh
been fun watching you write a book oh
man it's like having your first kid well
i
i've
been a writer my whole career in
academics and this is a different animal
oh that's not academics different
animals so yeah we were no nerds allowed
no there's no doubt that it's true
there's a lot of nerds involved in this
project too many nerds no it's good man
few in this building but yeah it's uh
it's good stuff we're excited about it
the book is really really good so lots
of good things happening around ramsey
right now the steel is going up on the
hill up here the ramsey event center
will be done in november holds 2500
folks
in a wonderful auditorium you'll be able
to come to events that we do here on the
campus
and uh they won't be canceled any reason
and james got a haircut that's another
big thing that's going on around here
it's great well you know i thought he
looked cleaner he does
yeah it's a big thing maybe he just took
a shower
but there's a lot of changes going on
around here well that's a breakthrough
it's a big breakthrough it's a
breakthrough did his wife do it two
years of working on my show he's like
you know what i think i'm gonna cut my
hair does his wife cut his hair uh i
don't get that we're not that close to
friends you're not okay he keeps this
thing secret uh it's he's probably more
like george or you he's got the fashion
hair thing going no george definitely
has the fashion here georgia's got the
uh yeah the grease in the hair stand
stands up like the fawns
yeah he works it now there's lots and
lots of stuff going on but hey man for
real proud of you for getting that thing
out of there this first one in almost a
decade right yeah eight years and uh and
and i am not like you i'm not a writer
um but i can sit down and have a
conversation
with the folks on the other side of this
microphone and that's what i do when i
sit down to the keyboard yeah and uh so
the books are ridiculously
conversational
and uh we put all of the uh
ramsey millionaire study in the back of
the book too which is a fun piece the
white paper from it and uh it's a fun
piece of research because of the uh i'm
a
statistical
nerd
and so when we were doing that
controlling the variables and
making sure that the research didn't
have a bias and it was completely
airtight and couldn't be questioned i
really enjoyed that yeah way more than i
should have so i like sticking that
white paper for that study in the back
because i had my fingerprints all over
that study being done and the company we
were using outside our team and research
team inside working together and
so all of that all that coming together
to tell you you can do this yeah we got
a culture that's a desperate need of a
light and hope man so congratulations
man we need it now
more than ever need to spread a little
hope
punch the old hump steelers in the nose
that's what we do around here don't be a
hope stealer
worse than a dream killer
it's their ugly cousin
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
still on baby step number one
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr
john deloney ramsey personalities my
co-host today you can hear him on the dr
john deloney show one of our most
popular and exploding podcasts where he
talks about relationships and mental
health and boundaries and family and wow
is it uh
motivating and entertaining and
informational it's all of those and so i
i just love the podcast personally and
good i really like it because i own it
it's working and he's awesome but
there's all of that too but yeah amazing
so be sure and check that out at uh
ramsey networks we're doing a bunch of
great podcast doctors dr johnson if you
have an actual question for him and
can't get through today email ask john
ramseysolutions.com
ask john
ramseysolutions.com ryan is in
cincinnati hey ryan how are you
i'm doing good how are you guys doing
better than i deserve what's up good
congrats on the book first of all thank
you so
i am um
just out of college i've been currently
in baby step two and i'm looking
uh i just did a repair on my car it's
about a thirty 3500 car and uh
i'm just trying to figure out
in the baby steps where
um potentially saving up for another
used car would come in
when my car breaks down for good after
baby step three
that's your b step three okay
3 500 car will get you through getting
out of debt and getting your emergency
fund in place
and then you save for and do other
things vacations cars
couches whatever that kind of stuff um
after baby step three but a new car as
long as you have one that is running is
not an emergency and until you get until
you get past the emergency fund you
don't do anything
except emergencies
yeah i just patched the alternator with
it uh and a couple of my mechanic
buddies uh
they're kind of saying that it's
near the end of its life so i've been
patching it oh i think it is i think i
think it's definitely near the end of
its life but it's going to get you
through
and your mechanic buddies aren't your
financial advisor they fix your car
that's true that's very true
okay
so you just man hey listen i've driven a
beater but here's the thing if you will
drive like no one else for a little
while later you'll get yourself in a
position you can drive anything you'll
drive like no one else
you know what i drive now anything i
want a couple of them
a couple anything i want
but yeah i mean yeah why not because but
you know you pay a price to win you get
yourself out of dadgum ditch right
yeah
okay awesome yeah i think i'm trying to
ignore my parents and some of the people
around me to
remember the
the baby steps because i'm still fairly
new to this they're trying to keep calm
well here's the thing i'm not suggesting
you drive a piece of crap the rest of
your life i'm suggesting you drive it
long enough that you get out of debt so
you never have to do this again and when
you when you fix a beater
it hurts let that pain motivate you to
get done even faster it's supposed to
like it's like it's like renting oh yeah
it's like you're throwing your money
away because i'm putting money in a crap
car yeah it hurts it's but hey listen
take pictures of the car
give it a name and tell the grandkids
about back in the day back in aught 22
when you drove that piece of junk and
that's before you were a millionaire
that's right this is what you do man you
pay a price to win and then you're the
old man on the porch that has some sense
i love it because you were a young man
that sought wisdom
you're cool man i like you all right
jennifer's in st paul minnesota jennifer
what's up
hi dave hi john um i wish i could say i
was doing a little bit better um
i'm 38 years old and uh the week before
christmas my 39 year old husband died oh
god
what happened
kidney disease um so he went quick at
the end even though it was
kind of a long year of appointments and
trying to figure things out i'm sorry
but he was to say
he was
he was in year 9 of a 10-year life
insurance policy
and you know
with the worst
coming to pass at this point
i'm just wondering
what to do i'm so sorry i'm heartbroken
for you jennifer man you got babies
thank you
yeah
we have a 15 year old
it's a 12 year old how they doing
you're making us cry but other than that
it's okay
no i just i just want to the thing is i
want to be
a really
responsible person with this money um
he's leaving approximately 750 000
and we had no debt and we recently moved
into a town home so the only debt we
have is a is a mortgage how much is it
and i just want
mortgages uh 230 thousand dollars okay
all right
the first and as i move forward i oh you
go ahead the first thing i want you to
do
is slow down yep
okay
you running out and being the wonderful
perfect controller of money in the
middle of the worst tragedy of your life
is not gonna happen
slow down
slow down okay okay you got time you got
plenty of money
don't touch it
pretend like it's not there buy food
keep the lights on
hug your babies and cry
slow down
okay does that feel good
okay
it
it takes a little while to be able to
breathe again
you're holding your breath half the time
now yeah you haven't taken a breath in
two years have you
not really
and and now it's just you're gulping
because this stuff hits you in waves
right now
so here's the thing
i i do not want you to do any major
decisions that can't be undone
for six months
okay i want you to spend that six months
grieving and healing and hurting
because that would make you a human
being and not a psychopath
normal people hurt when you have this
everybody listening is hurting with you
right now john and i are hurting with
you right now
and so that's all good so i'll give you
a couple mechanics and i want him to
step in and speak to the grief part of
the equation
mechanic number one it is okay if you
want to just go ahead and pay the
townhouse offer you you got a job are
you working
i was working very part-time as a
freelance marketer okay can you eat on
that if the house is paid off
yes sir okay eat on that just get back
to work
whenever you can and pay your bills and
don't touch the other money just go
ahead and pay off the house and put 500
000 in a cd and just let it sit there
for six months and cry and just cry
and you'll cry a little less every month
and your brain will clear up and it'll
be less foggy
six months from now than it is right now
that's called healing
it's called it's going call going
through the process and then you can
only after six months you can meet with
an investment advisor a smart investor
pro and they can help you invest this
money at that point
but i don't want you making those
decisions right now
i wouldn't i were you
hey let me tell you i've been married to
chevron sharon for 40 years or something
happens to her this is the exact thing
i'm gonna do
nothing yeah
i'm not gonna make any big decisions
because i know my brain will be uh mush
if that were to happen
now the good news is all of our estate
plan is predicated on me dying first so
i won't have to deal with it but um
which i kind of kind of scares me a
little bit because i think she has a
plan but um anyway john what are you
thinking yeah
the advice dave gave you is wise and i
want you to know you're going to have
people coming out of the woodwork to
tell you what to do what you should have
been doing oh my gosh i can't believe
you're waiting for this everyone's going
to have an opinion do you remember way
back when you were pregnant the first
time how many idiots
dropped their advice into you know what
i
mean
yeah get this bottle on that formula and
this um
same thing's going to happen baby
einstein
baby einstein videos yes
um i want yeah slow down and here's the
big key get people in your life you can
talk to
you cannot do the next six months by
yourself
so either get a professional who's gonna
walk alongside you get some friends get
some community get a church group get
people that will walk with you that you
can cry with everybody does grief
different but you got to do this with
other people your phrase always is and i
love it grief demands a witness every
time
you need people in your life walking
with you and you're not an inconvenience
no you're a gift
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
thank you for joining us america
dr john delony ramsey personality is my
co-host today today's the day
we've been
hearing people talk about cryptocurrency
and
single stock investments and
nothing down real estate and beanie
babies and the lottery and all these
ways you can get rich quick
and um
he who hastens to be rich will not go
unpunished
that was the bible
something to think about
and so i i've just watched it for 30
years and the number of people that get
rich after using get rich quick is
over time precisely zero
it doesn't work
so we're going to have a whole new thing
with this baby steps millionaires launch
where we have a huge event this coming
thursday night
called building wealth in 2022 we're
going to talk about the things that are
out there that are distracting people
and we're going to show you a real plan
as well
and
you know those of you that are haters be
sure you sign up because i'm going to
give you lots of reasons to hate
so just be ready you're gonna love it
it's gonna be like perfect for your
little youtube channel and stuff
so be sure you sign up um
buildingwealth2022 go to ram go to
ramseysolutions.com wealth it is a free
live stream over a hundred thousand
folks will be joining us this coming
thursday evening george campbell rachel
cruz and i our question of the day comes
from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee even if you screw
up miss measure pick the wrong color
they'll remake your window blinds for
free and we all need that kind of grace
when it comes to measuring things you
free samples free shipping and with the
new promos they run all the time you'll
save even more use the magic word ramsey
it's a great american company blinds.com
be sure to check them out
oh i thought you meant ramsay oh well
both are great
today's question comes from sally in
arkansas sally writes my boyfriend and i
have been together two years and are
talking about marriage he is debt free
he is what they call
a trust fund baby but there's one thing
i have an issue with and i don't know if
this is just me or something i shouldn't
worry about when i asked my boyfriend
how much is owed on his house he said i
don't know dad pays it
his house was a gift through an
inheritance i asked her ask him how much
he set aside for retirement investments
investments and he said again i don't
know my parents handle it am i
overstepping any boundaries i mean
shouldn't he know these things for when
his family passes
he should know these things for when he
like becomes a man i was gonna say he
should know these things when he becomes
a grown-up
and he gets married or before he gets no
like yesterday before he gets married
yeah
i'm assuming he's an adult
chronologically yes so sally two things
i want to address here number one
trust your gut
uh
i don't want you to ever have another
thing that you're worried about that you
don't bring up because you think uh
wonder if this is just me find out if
it's just me and ask and if people
actually love you in your life and you
ask them they'll answer you honestly and
directly and then y'all can move on with
your day so trust your gut on this and
number two your gut is correct yes man
he should know this stuff answers like
uh i don't know dad just does it it's
not a good answer so i want my daughter
marrying into that world
yeah ask yourself if you had a daughter
that you valued more than life itself
she was your sweet little princess
would you tell him her to marry this
joker
no
not because he's got wealth not because
his family has wealth
not because he has some money that has
come to him through inheritance but
because he doesn't know anything or do
anything right he's useless
he needs to get i'm sorry was that a
little blunt
so here's what i would do sally i would
say i was
before that i would say
okay so start the car in the driveway
put the keys in start the car and then
go in and sit down with him and say
the fact that you don't know how much
money you have or how much your house is
worth or your it scares me
and i will not be scared going into my
marriage
i want you to be a grown-up i want you
to act like an adult and if we're going
to go into this thing i need to know
where the money is i know how much we
owe what we owe on how we make money how
we don't make money where the
investments are i want to know these
things because i'm a part of this thing
moving forward
there's dignity
in producing
value in the marketplace you do not meet
people who are happy people
who do nothing do nothing they don't
exist they they sit on their butt on the
back of a yacht and do nothing these are
not happy people and if you sounds
romantic it sounds like a bad reality
show it sounds like a movie it sounds
like the end of a movie when somebody
got rich or they robbed a bank or they
did whatever
but
the truth is
serving others working
helping people
giving yourself fulfillment in that
process is what mature adults do to find
happiness this guy has never enjoyed
that proposition right and you talk
about dave like the doing nothing you
can flip that and i know a lot of people
that work really hard and don't make a
ton of money and they're the most joyful
they've got purpose they bring joy to
the to the people that they work for
they've got purpose in their life they
create things they're builders they're
whatever
gotta go do something this is this puts
you in such a position that all you do
is naval gaze it's just so much
introspection going on because he can't
do nothing else he doesn't do anything
else so it really it's just i don't
think you fix this one i think this
one's broken this is a run but if you
want to try you can do john's routine
i'm good with that
you sit down and go this was broken well
i mean it's not permanently broken but i
don't want my daughter marrying a
project no i'm not especially not a
project with this kind of money yeah
it's it's a well-funded dysfunctional
project that's right because here's the
other problem
it ain't just him he's married mom and
dad too yeah well these two characters
that are called his parents
suck as parents they don't have any
evidence
and you're marrying into that too and
and i'll guarantee you one of the two of
them is a control freak nut bag
crazy person
i'll guarantee you
don't you think i mean
who else does this to their children
people who get
their own satisfaction out of managing
grown-ups lives control the gut i got it
i'll just take care of it yeah that's
gonna see him man i'm telling you that's
in there i know nothing about psychology
but i'm old and i've seen a lot open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five this is fun
it's always good to have john on here i
learn things from him every time all
right gordon's with us in los angeles
hey gordon what's up hi dave hi john um
thank you for your help and advice you
give it's a blessing for your listeners
thank you how can we help sure
so i'll keep the question short i'm in
baby step 3d on 4.
with the buildback better bill stalled
in congress should i even try to do a
backdoor rough this year
well even if it didn't stall uh it's got
not going to go away for this year to be
the next year
and the back door the plugging of the
loophole for the
backdoor roth would be starting in 2022
but you can do one for this calendar oh
either way
and it's not gonna you know i i i think
they're
i mean i believe in the roth ira and i'm
thankful there is a back door because i
do it every year
now anything i can do to keep the hands
off
the government's hands off my money is a
good thing but the
honest truth is is it's a mistake
in the tax code that allows you to do a
backdoor it is a true loophole it's
legal and it's fine but it was a poorly
written bill that allows the wording
that allows this to go on and so it is
the essence in a tax loophole so
eventually
someone's going to write or some tax
code that's going to plug this puppy or
they're going to change the whole
philosophy around the roth and just
allow everybody to do it but the idea of
this was rich people shouldn't be able
to do roths
that was the whole idea on it because if
you make to over 200 000 a year you
don't qualify for a roth so you have to
do a backdoor roth but the way a
backdoor roth is is you open up an
after-tax ira and then you roll it over
to a roth ira 20 seconds later and so in
essence you get a roth which i do it
every year and i'm way overqualified so
and there's nothing wrong with it
nothing immoral nothing illegal nothing
right you know along those lines but uh
do it as many times as you can do it as
long as you can do it but i think
eventually unless they get off this
we're going to tax the rich because
they're evil thing and washington once
they get if they don't get off of that
they're going to eventually plug this
hole up so yeah definitely do it do it
do it just do it
until you can't fit no more this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your work
your money your relationships it's what
we do right here on the ramsey show
michael's in salem oregon hi michael
welcome to the show how can we help
hi dave how you doing better than i
deserve man what's up
awesome um so i work for a fallen sun
company me being the sun in it
um and i was kind of wondering do you
have any tips or advice on hiring our
first employee
and i was also going to ask is it nda or
non-complete
viable is that a good option or
what do you do
we're a graphic design and vehicle wrap
kind of company so we do anything
advertising for our clients apparel etc
in that sense
okay well getting into your business is
tough so i don't know why someone would
be a big threat to leave you and be in a
comp competitive situation and really
they wouldn't take anything with them
except just their two hands
yeah the the problem is a lot of times
um we've kind of had to have it happen
to us in the past and get burnt
um
they're gonna take the knowledge and you
know like the resources of where we get
our supplies
our kind of pricing behind the scenes
etc
um and then it just creates and breeds
competition if you're not really smart
about it well yeah you can you can have
you could have a simple two-page
contract or something drawn up that just
says there's proprietary
processes and vendor contacts
and customer contacts that you can't
take with you
um and if you do we will shut you down
that you're invited that's not even a
non-compete that's just there's
proprietary things we do that here in in
a very general sense we're not not as
strict as what you're talking about but
there's some just basic interest i mean
you can't steal a customer list that's
illegal i mean even without a contract
you can enforce that in any state as an
example
and i've had that happen a couple of
times and i just have to call them up
and go you know you can't do that and
and then they don't sometimes people are
just dumb and they don't realize it but
um
uh you know that that's the thing the
other thing is you fix a lot of this on
the higher
when you're hiring
and john you know talk let's talk about
screening
in the hiring process i think that makes
a big difference yeah that's a huge
difference is you get to know the person
that you're hiring you know their
character to know what their skill set
is
i i go back to that old zig ziglar quote
the only thing worse than
training somebody having them leave is
not training them and having them stay
and so i want to find somebody that i
can trust and really train well
and give them all the insights there and
then you and your family are going to
have to really be intentional about
the dynamic between you and your dad and
bringing in a third
like a a new person right who's not a
family member that's going to be a whole
different ball of wax
um but yeah you've got to have somebody
that you trust that you put through the
ringer and skills and character and what
they think about things do you like
being around them that's a big thing
like are we gonna get along here um it
just changes the dynamic of your
business yeah it's a small business by
definition so there's a lot you're gonna
be in the proximity with them all the
time and
there's nothing
illegal or wrong with saying
i don't want to hang out with this
person all day
i mean they may be good at their job but
you know but in our in our culture today
we've
uh
deteriorated in the hiring process to
think if we just hire someone to do the
job that that's the only responsibility
we have
and it's just the very minimum right you
got to do a whole lot more than that
around here we call it are they a
culture fit
and it we we don't lose people very
often for not being able to do their job
but we do lose some folks that aren't
culture fits
meaning they don't want to be around us
we won't be around them yeah and so one
of us makes the decision in that process
and go bye-bye and so and and so yeah
you do all that you love them well the
thing i would tell you to do in order to
get the right people in the building is
the number one mistake people make as
they first start adding
to their team is they don't take enough
time
i want you to interview them a minimum
of four times
preferably six and that sounds laborious
it sounds over the top but i tell you
what about that fifth interview sitting
on the back porch somewhere with a cup
of coffee they'll say something you go
not doing that
and you know because people can dress up
and say stuff for about two or three
interviews that anything that make you
happy but you just keep hanging out with
them a little bit eventually if there's
something crazy going on they'll reveal
they're crazy and you'll reveal yours
and let's be real clear about that you
and your dad have a special kind of
weird that y'all how y'all interact what
y'all think is funny what do you think
someone's going to have to want to spend
time with you all so i think that those
interviews go both ways right
you know i never thought of that because
i just thought everybody wanted to be
around me
except oh it's the narcissism thing
there you go there it is yeah
but no you're right i mean it's not
ramsay's not for everybody it's not and
that's okay i'm still like i'm really
okay with it yeah unbelievably okay with
it
i there's a lot of jobs that we could do
uh like i you know you do the ski i have
a skill set for but
we're not gonna like hanging out with
each other every single day eight hours
ten hours working late nights figuring
out finishing projects together and
that's okay that's part of the it's part
of the fit conversation i think you and
your dad need to sit down and have a
conversation about what are we looking
for what's what skill set do we need
what kind of what ways can we train this
person over time what responsibilities
they want to take from us and you and i
we may yell at each other we may
cold shoulder each other let's be honest
about that when we bring somebody in
yeah but the work environment yeah and
when i came here y'all are honest about
the work environment this is how we
talked about what it is like here yeah
yeah very a lot we talk about a lot
that's right because we want you to self
select out if you think we're weird and
we are kind of weird and there's enough
meetings that i got to see some of it
live right i got to see some of the
disagreements or this and i think that
and i got to see it how it happens and i
think those are healthy yeah
you know how to have a good argument uh
and and so last thing is this
if you're going to grow your business
and you're going to add your head to
your team
two things are going to happen
over time
one is it's going to be the most
rewarding
part of running a business is having
high quality people in your life walking
alongside you
causing your dream to happen and it
becomes their dream
and it's soul enriching and it's awesome
the second thing is going to happen is
some people are going to betray you
they're going to lie about you
they're going to cheat and they're going
to break your heart
and you better get ready for both and
you better enjoy the ride baby because
both are going to happen if you hire
more than one person
if you hire one person you're going
gonna get one or the other but we don't
know which
but you just keep it up i mean i got
some of my best friends on the planet
some of the highest quality human beings
i know work on this team yeah and
some of the biggest jerks on the planet
that
man oh man i could just go off on
used to work here
and
oh man
and it just breaks your heart and some
of them i'm not angry with but you just
make you kind of want to throw up a
little bit you know that i put money
into that and i poured my life into that
and it's just uh that's part of what it
is and but hey it's the joy of doing you
know your other options stay home do
nothing no thank you right
let's bring it man game on yeah it's uh
it is it's enriching it's kind of like
you know
i guess the rest of things in life you
just embrace the good and
and there's always there's never a
hundred percent pure no awesomeness with
anything no you need that that pain side
to balance out the pleasure side of the
teeter totter there how do you know what
it is
when you hired your first employee here
at a
what is a really a large family business
was that strange was that weird
very weird very weird but he stayed 20
years yeah so they're pretty good on the
first yeah the second one stayed
45 days
[Laughter]
swing and a mess
yep yep i was so good at it i thought i
could do it again of course
and the third one stayed
that took her place
two years or three years yeah now which
is pretty good and we're still friends
yeah wonderful and by the way i'm
friends with all three of those yeah but
i can imagine the first hire when you
have a family business it's it feel it
would feel really personal because
you're taking my name you're taking the
thing that i've built from nothing i
don't know it feels like you'd feel more
personal to me yeah i guess but i i
think if you own the business
well it makes a family business i guess
yeah instantly yeah it's just i mean
ours has got our name on it like in the
spotlight and stuff so that's even
weirder yeah yeah but if you he owns a
sign company or a graphics company for
putting wraps on cars and stuff but it's
his babe he's got his name on it and
them screwing up
mess up his personal reputation at
church yeah yeah you know that stuff
that's real that's very very just know
it's going to be weird yeah so it's
going to be weird it's part of the joy
of the whole process
have fun with it good question
i hang on i'll send you a copy the
entree leadership book number one
bestseller our playbook on how we've
grown this business from a card table in
our living room to where we are today
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america this is a show about
your relationships your work
your life and your money the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five joining me in studio
for the first time our one of our brand
new ramsey
personalities
we've known she was here for a while but
it's time to tell you guys out there
that she's here christina ellis has
joined the team she's an absolute rock
star we are so thrilled that she's with
us welcome thank you i'm so excited to
be here oh we're excited to have you now
you guys have watched borrowed future
you've seen christina on there she's an
expert on scholarship she had a
best-selling book called confessions of
a scholarship winner
and so you were one of our experts that
commented in the documentary on borrowed
future on getting scholarships and on
how
absurd the whole student loan crisis is
you're
one of the nation's leading experts in
that whole space and you get to join
this team and fight this fight and we're
so glad you're here i'm so honored to be
here and i'm excited to fight alongside
you guys
so you learned about scholarships and
the whole student loan debacle
first hand for your
for your own self you know i mean like
you you grew up uh your dad passed away
when you were young tell us your story
yeah well the first day of my freshman
year of high school my mom she sat me
down and she basically said christina i
love you and i believe in you but
there's just no way that i can support
you financially once you graduate from
high school so
you got to figure out your own way to
pay for college and at first i was
shocked i thought like why are you
telling me this i'm a freshman in high
school but at the same time i knew that
she was just trying to help you know my
dad he did pass away when i was seven
and my family really struggled
financially after that so even though
that statement was really hard to choke
down i know she just wanted to set me up
for success so she actually there's
nothing like a single mom to give you
clarity oh yeah and my mom own
everything and she is a strong
personality so she is very driven and
was like you are going to college and
and i'm not paying for it because i
can't right so what are we gonna do
exactly so she told me about
scholarships and she basically cast this
vision she was like if you work hard
enough now i know that you can go to a
great college and start fresh with zero
debt and at the time i was kind of like
i don't know about this i wasn't a
perfect student and i wasn't a star
athlete so i didn't know how that could
happen but she just had so much faith in
me that i started to believe in myself
and i just absolutely dove into research
on you know how can i win scholarships i
read every book i could find every
article i interviewed alumni from my
high school and i figured out i just
wanted to know you know how can i stand
out in this process and be successful
and she kind of held you accountable you
had to write the essays you had to fill
out the applications oh yeah she held me
accountable and she was right there with
me you know i've always said that you
know what she couldn't give me and money
for school she gave me in the effort she
put in walking alongside of me
cheerleader and coach oh yeah she was
right there in the ring with me and i'm
just so thankful now that she cast that
vision because so how many applications
did you fill out and ask for
scholarships i filled out over 50
applications 50 yes that's all well i
actually was pretty ocd about the
process though i the ones you but you
hit home runs on almost all of them then
because tell people how much you raised
in scholarships yeah i won over a half a
million dollars in scholarships
500 000 and you end up you end up
graduating from vanderbilt debt-free yes
and i got a master's from belmont
completely paid for with scholarships
yeah
okay i think that kind of wraps it up
wow i mean and that you guys see what
now while we're
enamored with christina and just
thrilled that she's on the team
she's got a great story and she uh
published a book called confessions of a
scholarship winner the story that you
just told there but in much more length
and in details on how to get the
scholarship right yes and that book was
a bestseller
and um you actually we had you actually
on the show
a long time ago to promote the book or
you just called in and i got got some of
the story out of you or what was it i
remember there's some kind of a back
thing there i forgot what it was i did
the debt free town hall whatever you all
released for degree oh okay yeah i came
out to support y'all and was on the
panel that day and got to kind of share
my story okay it wasn't a random call
then okay so we got you in there because
i've had people call in they got great
scholarships and that kind of stuff over
the years and i didn't know if that was
when i'm where we connected with you but
uh so we had the debt free with a
debt-free degree book that we did that
was a bestseller with anthony o'neil and
so you were on that town hall i remember
that and then we uh of course said oh we
gotta call christina we're doing the
documentary because she can make the
case on scholarships that can be done
and her material and her background her
knowledge of that space
will
do that and so if you haven't seen
borrowed future folks it's the
documentary that we put out uh
about the destruction of the student
loan industry to
america how it is destroying the
american dream and uh christina's kind
of got the antidote over here part of
the part of the antidote is scholarships
part of it is
college selection part of it's a lot of
other things and so she's joining ramsey
to help us with the money space and
obviously we'll be speaking over this
whole
college issue this whole student loan
issue this scholarships issue but not
limited to that we're going to talk
about money of any kind right yes i'm
very excited it's it's awesome to join
this team especially with borrowed
future coming out it's like it's time
that we really disrupt this industry the
student loan space it's taking advantage
of 18 year olds it's taking advantage of
teenagers and so to get to be on this
team and just
bang on the walls of this toxic industry
is so exciting yeah we're gonna kick
their door down man that's what we're
gonna do cause a holy ruckus yes let's
do it yeah i like it i like it so and uh
this lady's got the story to do it so
yeah her dad passes away with cancer
when she's seven years old her mom is a
single mom raises her sister down and
says you have to get scholarships she
goes and gets a half a million dollars
worth goes to vanderbilt and belmont
with a master's degree comes out zero
debt and so listen any of the rest of
you that have any problems uh we're just
going to send her to you and say shut up
i mean you can do this because
it just is a matter of applying a system
and believing you can
absolutely and that's the thing about my
story is i wasn't a perfect student and
i wasn't a star athlete i had a lot of
obstacles standing in my way so that's
one of my biggest passions is just
helping people believe in themselves and
that no matter what your background no
matter what challenges you're facing you
can overcome them and you can get a
debt-free degree you do not have to sign
up for student loans there is a way to
do this now there's success principles
woven all through your story in your
life
that can apply to not only the whole go
to college thing but just getting out of
debt thing becoming a millionaire thing
and so you joining the whole money team
here of the ramsey personalities money
team with rachel and with uh uh with
george and me and and we get to talk
about this stuff for the for the rest of
your life this is awesome yes this is
going to be fun i'm excited about it
it's really good uh we've also got
another ramsey personality that has
joined the team we'll be introducing you
to in a few months and uh christina's
been here for a few and uh we take a
little time get a little on-ramp going
around here before we bring these folks
out and make sure you get to know them
but you'll be hearing a whole lot more
from christina in the coming months and
years be ready she is an
amazingly smart talented young woman and
we are so excited to have you on the
team welcome honored to be here thank
you dave so check out christina ellis
and if you want to check out her book
from before she was here it's called
confessions of a scholarship winner
it'll tell you the story and uh game oh
baby
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
dr john deloney my co-host today here on
the ramsey show the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
i mentioned borrowed future the
documentary
when uh christina was on a few minutes
ago if you haven't seen it yet over 150
000 folks have now viewed it um it is a
um
it's uh officially a big deal you can
watch it at borrowed future dot com on
apple tv on amazon prime or google play
it's pretty much everywhere
so check it out it's called borrowed
future
all about the uh
the debacle that is the student loan
industry john deloney is on there uh we
actually taped you as an expert prior to
you coming here as well and i was here
you were here all right
okay yeah all right i couldn't remember
all right
but uh with his phd in higher ed he had
some things to say that are very
interesting be sure and check all of
that out nathan's with us in pensacola
hi nathan welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave a longtime listener i appreciate
your show and definitely live by almost
all the advice you have well thank you
how can i help
so
my wife and i
are looking at possibly buying a
property it's a little bit more
expensive than what i'm used to buying
so um
right now we own a home and we're just
trying to figure out if it makes sense
to take our our current investments and
just basically liquidate our current
investments and then now uh go into debt
with a mortgage that would be probably
about a 300 000 mortgage after we're
done with liquidating all of our
expenses all of our debt i'm sorry all
of our
assets
okay how old are you
we're 47 47 or 46 wait all of your
assets you mean you're pulling
retirement out
no no no um the retirement i can't touch
until uh later but we've got um uh
listening to you guys like uh smart
investor kind of stuff and uh we went
with uh a smart investor pro here in
pennsylvania that's cool so you have how
much money in investments that are
non-retirement
um probably about uh 600k total
okay
and your current residence has how much
equity in it
about 400 okay so you're buying a
million three house
[Music]
it's gonna be a little bit less than a
million three but it'll be a little over
a
million
okay i missed how you get three hundred
thousand dollars in debt because i got a
million dollars here 600 and 400.
so i guess uh
the mortgage might not be quite 300 um
it'll be probably closer to 200. when we
uh
when you have all the closing costs and
everything into it
[Music]
okay so you're talking about you're not
going to net 400 out of your house
no we should we shouldn't have 400 out
of the house
and you have 600 in investments
and savings and everything yes that's a
million
and the house is a million
there's not two hundred thousand dollars
in closing costs there's not a twenty
percent closing cost there's no such
thing
so i guess it's just kind of an uneasy
feeling going with a higher home value
and just i guess the biggest that i have
is it doesn't make sense to liquidate
the uh the investments that we have
right now i wouldn't buy the house if i
didn't
because you're you're going to go into
debt so it's the same question of if i
had a paid 4 million house would i go
borrow 600 000 on it to put money into
investments
no i wouldn't
not taking the money out of the
investments and putting them on the
house is the same thing as borrowing on
your house to do that so you should not
buy the house unless you're willing to
use the investments to do it what's your
household income
right now it's probably about 110.
and how old are you guys
4846 will you be able to afford the
taxes on a million dollar property at a
hunt with a hundred thousand dollars a
year just to just to maintain the
property keep the lights on this thing
keep the yard mode
uh yes we will
[Music]
yeah um florida's got some generous um
disabled veterans tax benefits
okay
so why why do you want to buy a million
dollar property
it's something my wife and i have always
dreamed about living on water and this
is an opportunity to do so right now
okay
i don't think you're going to need a
mortgage or if you do it's a very very
small one and you're going to turn
around and get that paid off as fast as
you can if you're sitting in this
property debt-free
within a couple of years then i'm fine
with this idea
if you want to do it um
the thing that's out of balance that
you're feeling is is that um the vast
majority of your net worth is now tied
up in your single family home
that does not that does not generate an
income
it does grow in value but it does not
generate an income
and so um you know you're going to have
to really pour on the coals and build
some investments by the fact that you
don't have any house payment
in the near future
to make this work but no you don't need
a 300 000 mortgage the numbers you keep
giving me that you act like they add up
and they don't add up
i mean 600 and 400 is 1 million and you
buy a million dollar house for a million
dollars and you use a million dollars
you shouldn't have a mortgage
uh and so
this makes me uncomfortable like that
makes me uneasy that's a lot the reason
is that all everything you own is going
into this house
except your retirement
and uh it is it's out of balance it's
too much really yeah uh but if you're
paying cash for it i think you can
tolerate it as long as you turn around
and start dumping money into retirement
really really quick uh would i do this
if i were in your shoes no i wouldn't
yeah
no i wouldn't maybe that's i wouldn't
either because i don't want that much of
my net worth
making 110 000 tied up in a single
family house that does not create income
and i'm thinking of it if the air
conditioner goes out on this million
dollar house
it's going to be an expensive repair or
if the driveway needs to be or if i got
to do some plumbing work
it's all so expensive
everything let me just 100 of the houses
break yeah yeah 100 of them need crap
done to them and um
brand new no matter who built them no
matter where they are
i mean i'm in a lot of real estate and
there's just uh they they eat money yeah
so you're put to your point that's good
yeah i think i i you know the more i
started to talk this through listening
to john too
i'm risk averse though so let me say
that a lot but i mean i i
there's just no margin here there's no
there's no way they can't come back to
march there's no wiggle there's no
wiggle room
one of you gets sick i wanted to get
something life goes sideways yeah now
you got a lot of wiggle room with 600
000 in the bank so probably what i would
do is take your 600 and pay off your
current residence
uh which you should have done anyway if
you're listening to me but that's that
part where you said you just did part of
what i teach i remember that part i
didn't drive by it i heard it
and um
then
then i would save like a crazy person
and i might do this deal in five years
where i've got 500 000 left over
after i buy it now that started if you
had 500 000 left over non-retirement
after you move in there
you do a million dollar house 110 000
incomes is is low for a million dollar
house but if you're paying cash for it
for whatever reason it's okay but you do
need some liquidity
and it doesn't need to be
freaking 90 of your net worth that's
just that's out of balance or can you
save up some money and and go
multiple weeks instead of lake house a
year and i mean i don't even mind if you
buy you know if your dreams live on the
water i agree i like living on the water
i've got i've got properties on the
water i like it
but um water water is amazing yeah but
the uh but but it's not amazing if it
steals your piece that it gives you
peace yeah so and there's no margin here
no margin it's dangerous that's a
dangerous deal no i wouldn't do it i'm
going to retract i wouldn't do it
because
i don't like the fact there's no wiggle
room what i would do is i pay off my
house today
and i'd start saving like a crazy person
and make this a three to a five year
dream
and just keep piling up cash and keep
investing with a paid for house but
you're gonna do what you're gonna do
because you already
don't do some of the stuff we teach so
that's up to you you get to decide but
then that's
that's what i would do if i woke up in
your shoes
um
i find people don't have margin with
their time they don't have it with their
relationships they don't have it with
work they don't have it with money we
just have a margin free society now man
well they just it it um there's friction
at greats they get freight ins yeah and
you get frayed at the ends and it's just
um because everything's pushed to the
edge
and it takes what would have normally
been a blessing
and and
you you know you add two doses of stress
to it and all of a sudden you don't the
thing you're supposed to be in love with
you hate and when you think of it uh
psychologically our brains were designed
to run at that level when a lion was
chasing us not to live like that yeah it
just rattles everything to our core
you know it's a big old house with a
lion chasing you around inside that you
just parked the line in the front yard
yeah that's right so we've already
deteriorated tiger king right here this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage kelvin and emily are
with us hey guys how are you hi good
good to have you guys where do you all
live uh we're from nashua uh new
hampshire ah new hampshire welcome to
nashville and all the way to the south
to do a debt-free screen all the way
through the snow love it try to get away
from it but it's here too thank you for
bringing it it was here when you got
here but it's gone now it doesn't stay
long in tennessee so how much do you pay
off two hundred and fourteen thousand
dollars in this year and two months
plus we catch for our wedding and we
catch for my wife school oh wow very
cool very cool what's your degree in
i am a nurse and a pandemic
i'm also in school to be a nurse
practitioner okay
and what's your degree in
uh i'm a truck driver oh okay good very
cool good for you guys you guys got
after it then huh yeah you get just
knocking this out how long did this 214
000 take to pay off since you're in two
months six years and two months wow all
right and your range of income during
that six years we started ninety five
thousand dollars and we end up at two
hundred thousand dollars wow y'all are
killing it so what kind of debt was the
214 thousand we paid off our house
look at the weird people
what's this house worth 200 000
say what now 300 300 000.
i love it yeah way to go it's awesome
have you had your first month where you
had no mortgage paid but you got that
your everything deposited yeah it feels
amazing it's amazing yes that's how
we're here it's
wow
congratulations thank you
so what started you on this ramsey stuff
six years ago to get out of debt tell us
your journey tell us your story well
dave
i came to this country in 2003.
when i got my first job i was working in
the factory i was making 675 hours while
i was working there they made a
presentation about 401k
uh a close friend told me do not invest
your money in there because they're
going to steal your money i did believe
it so i did not invest in there oh wow a
few day a few years down the road
i was uh searching to through the radio
i found npr that they were talking about
when you retire you need to have like a
million dollar in order to be able to
retire
i thought in my head that it is
impossible there is no way a middle
class working family are able to
accumulate that amount of money
so a few years down the road one day i
found this guy named dave ramsey talking
about finance people calling and he
answered their question and he said
uh henry of finance the way your grandma
went the only reason we gave our tiffin
back then
um i started listening to it for about a
month about a month i decided to bring
it in my house and when he brought it
home it wasn't like you were a curse
word but more like a new best friend who
just like moved in dave ramsey said this
dave ramsey said that
and we had the envelopes and the magnets
and the chart and our kids are doing
chores based on commission with the
triangle all in it was super awesome
because i grew up conservative so i
didn't have any consumer debt i had paid
for college originally my first degree
but i just didn't know what the
direction i never thought retirement i
didn't know how to do that i didn't even
think about having a will because i
didn't think that maturely yet and so to
be able to articulate and put it all on
paper it was really awesome to like give
a direction and be like good good
stewards of our money so and now we're
millionaires we're millionaires too
[Applause]
yeah that's awesome baby steps
millionaires yeah i love it yeah on the
day we launched the book yeah it's
awesome yeah
yeah
well we got we have an actual copy for
you that we'll give you and sign it for
you this is so cool you guys it is super
cool very very neat well done very well
done
so uh yeah from 6.75 an hour coming to
this country you've got a dominican yeah
uh shirt on is that where you're from
yep okay cool so you come here from the
dominican republic from the big dr
and end up in a factory it's 6.75 cents
an hour to
now uh
what is that 18 years later yes from
there you're a millionaire yeah you owe
nobody nothing i don't know it's a real
american dream it's it's hard to think
and i don't even believe in myself
[Laughter]
that we made it
to here
i i believe it i definitely believe it
it's amazing so what's the hardest thing
on your marriage as y'all went through
this for 66 years a long time you got
three beautiful young kids they wanted
stuff they needed stuff how'd y'all make
that make that work well for me
that i came for another country when you
come here for me it was no har at all
because in the first day that i came to
this country i felt i was living as a
king right away
i was his biggest trouble i was his
biggest hurdle i did not i'm middle
class american i need i need a 12-foot
christmas tree
like i need three to four to 17 pumpkins
at halloween and so yeah when you come
from the br you know that's a want well
when you when you are with somebody with
everything as a want i'm like dagnabbit
like i i don't need anything because i
live in america
and it was awesome it's awesome to be
content because if you're not content
with what you have
then how are you going to be content
with more because we didn't have that
consumer debt so it's not like
we were trying so hard we didn't have to
be beans and rice but calvin loves beans
and rice so we were
and i love tuna sandwiches but it was
really it was really hard it's really
hard when you don't have consumer debt
you work full-time jobs you're going to
school you have kids and to still scrimp
and save and shop second hand and spray
paint my patio furniture but we did it i
love it and you're millionaires
yeah and as a nurse right now
i
my job i really do love my job i love i
have a great crew hviu um but i really
didn't want to be stuck in a place where
i couldn't be happy and it's so freeing
it is so freeing
to to be able to go anywhere yeah
whatever you want to do yeah you can
decide now yeah yeah it's uh it changes
your career path it changes
everything so kelvin uh your family
cheering you on through this process or
telling you that this is crazy they tell
me this is crazy
and how the how how do they act now
well still they were crazy they they
still think we're like weird these are
crazy millionaires over there yeah my
older sister i introduced dave ramsey to
her she just paired up her how wow
she doesn't matter that was because dave
rincey but i know that was the reason
why
she didn't want you to get credit for it
exactly yeah that's all it is she's the
oldest sister that's the way they are
yes exactly and i know you all know this
but you got three little ones over here
that will never understand
the burden you're talking about well
julian are my middles there was the only
sixth grader who knew the difference
between a debit and a credit card yes
and we went to pay off the mortgage when
we waited for them to come out of school
so we did it as a family and they just
know that having a credit card is is
just not in our religion and a car loan
is not necessary it is absolutely not
necessary nor is paying for school like
you know getting a loan all right get
them up on the stage let's tell
introduce them what are their names and
ages this is kevin he's 16.
this is julian he is
13. and this is
it's you
this is issa she just turned 12 on on
sunday so we're here on her birthday
happy birthday
love it love it love it well well done
you guys we're very proud of you guys
thanks all right what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is you
have to budget and you have to be
content i think you need to have
a goal to be worth to sacrifice for yeah
my i want to give my kids the
opportunity that i didn't have and i
want to change my family three you did
brother you did my man i mean you
completely did mike dropped man yeah you
did it
if they got half the cents that you got
you set them up mathematically where
you've changed your family tree and to
be happy to be content it's about being
happy with what you have yeah well done
well done that's so powerful hey you you
don't fully believe it yet
no no no no uh kelvin you know it sunk
in yet oh no not at all he's still he's
still wondering if there's something
coming up behind him hey you did it my
man yeah you did it you did it yeah
congratulations and we got here which is
also his second dream because you're
best friends i don't know if you know
that
and we we saw you in lowell so i'm sure
you recognize us from the balcony i've
been living in your spare bedroom so
there you go
we ought to be friends exactly this is
awesome you guys are amazing so very
very well done thank you all right we
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you because you are one
yeah yeah
and a copy of total money makeover to
give it to some of the family that
hadn't figured it out yet let's disrupt
them very well done you guys kelvin and
emily what a great story new hampshire
214 000 paid off and they became
millionaires six years and two months
making 95 to 200. count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
yeah baby yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you for joining us america dr john
dolone ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones a triple eight eight
two five five two two five you jump in
so john before we move on to the calls
um
kelvin our our last debt free screamer
there from the dr from the dominican
republic it is worth noting
in the uh belief chapter in baby steps
millionaires
that um
the data that we have says that if you
move to this country from another
country legally you immigrate legally
that you are four times more likely to
become a millionaire than one of us
homegrown
and you you have to wonder why that is
and uh in my mind
my my theory my hypothesis is that
uh in talking with the kelvins over the
years is they came here because
they really believe this is the land of
opportunity and they went about getting
their
portion of the dream yeah
because they believed it was there they
just had to go get it
and so he came here he didn't come here
to work 675 in a factory
he came here to dream to hit get the
dream the 675 just first stop
and um
when you
talk to folks that have gone through
that
that that belief
that it's there if i go do what i'm
supposed to do
not there's no victim there's no
entitlement mentality there's no nothing
that that comes with a someone coming to
this country legally
illegally you've got all kinds of other
barriers that you trouble you get into
and
uh legal issues and you know you can get
deported all kinds of other things can
happen but families that come here and
are able to to um
assimilate
and uh utilize the power of this
capitalistic economy for their own
benefit believe
that they can
they go do it more often than we do yeah
i i over the years i've had so many
countless international students that
we've had private conversations with
the just
are perplexed at the amount of
opportunity
that they would see their classmates
squandering
they i mean they it was this sense of
do they not underst
there's just it's opportunity everywhere
everywhere you look you can do whatever
you want you can and it was this it was
almost
it was it was inspiring to be around
them i loved being with international
students because they were just so
wide-eyed about oh you can do this or
this or this or this go make it all
happen and you you can just do that just
go do it and you can you're free yeah
and there's people that will buy that
yes and uh and they walk into a
supermarket where they wondered if they
were gonna have cheese yeah and there's
nine thousand kinds yeah yeah yeah it's
it's inspiring to be around folks like
yeah the abundance that we live in and
have
take for granted and grow up in the
level of abundance is
uh it doesn't come home until there's a
shortage it doesn't come home until
something else happens i mean you know
these supply chain things are giving
people a feeling about what it is like
to live other places oh i mean you can't
just call upon it all and have it land
magically in your front yard i mean i
can't i can't push a button on my
computer people bring it to my front
porch that's right what or it's going to
be three days instead of one it's
yeah it's a it's very interesting and i
also think it's important to note
be careful where you get your money
advice from because somebody who loves
that guy told him they're going to steal
your money maybe in their home country
they did right they might take your
money
but be careful where you get your money
advice from take it from somebody who's
been there who you can trust well here's
a good idea i don't care where you come
from or who you're talking to
don't take financial advice from broke
people i mean yeah hello yeah because i
guarantee you the guy said that he was
going to steal it was broke you know
just another another guy there making
675 right and i guarantee you he was and
so there's lots of broke people with
opinions about money
it's very interesting
marcus is with us marcus is in orlando
florida hey marcus welcome to the ramsay
show
uh hi david john how you guys doing
great man how can we help
uh so i just graduated from college in
december and i'm taking a new job in
february congratulations what's your
degree in
uh civil engineering oh excellent what's
the name
what's the new job paying
80 000 a year okay marcus get to work we
got a lot of stuff that needs to be
civilly engineered my man
you're going to be working for a long
time brother get to work get to fixing
it
yup i hear you um what's your question
man what's up
the
job i'm taking is a few hours away from
my parents house
in orlando so
i'm gonna have to buy a car here and
getting a lot of different advice i
guess from family members and friends on
whether to go new or used and like
looking at
new prices versus use prices i'm not
seeing like a huge difference i guess
when where i've been looking so i was
wondering if you could offer any advice
on where to go for that uh you buy used
and
because even a used car that's say like
15 to 20 000 yep dollars right that'd
have to take a loan out on either no
you're not taking out a loan on anything
you gain money
um yeah it's
i have
about
let's say like 9 000 in savings and then
um like a decent sized investment
account how much is in your investment
account
about 70 000
is that in a retirement account
um no it's in a taxable okay pay cash
for your car son buy a car dude
you don't go into debt you got 70 000
so it's cool if i'd sell investments to
buy a car you're dead come right before
you take out a car payment because let
me tell you what the difference is right
let's say you owned a 15 000 car that
was paid for would you go borrow money
on it to put money into investments
only if you're stupid
yeah i guess you're right and it's the
same thing it's still a balance sheet
issue okay it's the same exact thing i
just did it backwards i reverse
engineered your question so you're
definitely paying cash for a car and you
buy a used one here's the thing
cars
are awesome i love cars i'm a car guy
i'm a gear guy i just love loud mufflers
i'm a redneck
it's awesome man
and but but here's the thing they go
down in value it's the largest thing we
all buy that goes down in value the
biggest mistake brand new college
graduates make is they go buy a brand
new car to say thank you to themselves
for graduating and they put a big butt
payment on it
you all your friends are doing it
and they're all
and they're all screwing up and your
parents saw how much money your new
salary is and their mouth dropped wide
open and then they told you to go buy
yourself a brand new car yep
yeah that's pretty accurate and besides
that with all the supply chain stuff and
the shortages the used cars are
ridiculous so you might as well buy a
new one anyway everybody rationalizes
their butt off no
so hey for what hey for what it's worth
to let you know this isn't a theory i
make more than 80 000
and i've got more of my retirement
accounts than you do and i just bought a
used car for my wife what'd you pay for
it
what did we pay for it a lot okay a lot
but you bought used but we bought used
wrote a check for it paid cash good
called it good good okay so that's what
you do i if i were in
maybe go back let me go back because i'm
just we're just chopping him up what
what uh uh what's your income going to
be 80 000
yes correct you did say that he's gonna
make 80 yeah okay i'll miss that all
right so uh yeah buy a 15 or a 20 000
car and write a check and pay cash for
it
and then build your emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses which
you pretty much have you just need to
reallocate it to that and then start
your investing and you're going to be a
millionaire very very quickly if you
continue to buy very large things that
go down in value and you continue to buy
very large things that go down in value
on payments you will be middle class
you will not build wealth
most middle class people do three or
four stupid things continuously
throughout their lives and they never
break through into wealth
car payments and buying brand new cars
is one of them whole life life insurance
which is the payday lender of the middle
class is another one
okay and you just get hammered by these
industries that are completely taking
you
to the the thing and i know some of
these people giving you advice mean well
but they really aren't doing that well
with their finances so you don't need to
take their advice if the last engineer
that uh that that last engineer the guy
you work with the last thing he did was
a bridge that fell down i don't really
need his consulting on my next project
you know same thing okay broke people
shouldn't be giving you financial advice
but they do we were just talking about
that and something about you knows that
that's why you called you get a lot of
you got a lot of people
jawing at you you're making a great
salary but something about you knows
i
don't want to get out of college and be
free and then immediately sign myself
back up for debt so i'll tell you what
i'm gonna send you a copy of baby steps
millionaires as your graduation present
show you how to be a millionaire
and i have shown more people how to be
millionaires than just about anybody on
the planet right now so you hold on and
i've actually done it by the way so
check it out this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit the ramsay show.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
as we talk about your work your
relationships your life and your money
all right here on the ramsey show you
call in with questions about any of the
above triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five tracy's gonna
start us off this hour in columbus ohio
hi tracy how are you hi this is such a
happy moment i can't believe i get to
talk with you today thank you so much
well i'm honored i can't believe i get
to talk to you how can i help
okay i don't know if you want i have
everything written down
so i just retired from teaching after 36
years in july wow and then um
yeah what i realized was i made a giant
financial mistake but i got everything
i've got my good stuff down too
um
i really um
i really didn't do much in the way i
didn't know how to invest so can i tell
you what i what i did do and then you
could tell me what i should be doing
next okay um
well i've been out of debt most of my
life so that part's good um
i have 189 thousand dollars in moderate
stocks it's an uh
thing called voya i have two cabins and
13 acres it's all one complex
it's it's worth at least four hundred
thousand dollars
um i have a condo in south carolina i
paid ninety thousand for it so it might
be worth a hundred thousand right now i
got that right before the pandemic hit
it's very
modest um
my income right now is 41 000
a year
i have 10 000 in my emergency fund i
have 85 000 in savings
i have a small piece of land that's
worth seven to ten thousand dollars
right now
where was the part that you did wrong
well
it's been a very big adjustment to live
on 41 thousand dollars oh you mean
quitting your job okay
well no everybody told me like i should
have well no not everybody wait a minute
i just don't think i did what i should
have done for investment and i don't
know what to do now for the cabins and
the 13 acres generate an income
um yes i have
40 000 now i just got the last one paid
off um about four years ago
i go through a rental company so they're
um vacation rentals and how do you make
a year
for each cabin i clear 40 000.
she make 80 000 a year off these cabins
i'm sorry that's incorrect i've i am so
sorry i'm a little bit nervous okay um
i've got 40 000
per each cabin saved up right now i've
been what do they make a year
what do they make a year
okay what do they make a year profit 40
000 profit each cabin so 80 000 a year
yes i'm sorry yes sir and you have a 41
000 income plus an eighty thousand
dollar income
yeah i really haven't been using that
income i've been putting it back into
the cabins because they always need
work okay i'm talking about
if you have to put the money back in you
haven't made a profit yes profit is
after your expenses and includes repairs
or upgrades
right now this year i'm at forty
forty thousand in i i i don't think
you're making eighty thousand profit i
think you're probably making fifty 000
profit
you probably need to put 30 back in in
expenses and repairs upgrades every year
keep them going keep them moving along
so but that's okay that still means you
have a 90 000 income to live on if you
budget it out that way which i think you
can do you've done a good job good job
okay
is your house paid for in columbus as
well
yeah i paid it off in seven years what's
it worth
i would say it's probably worth 125 to
150 it's a condominium you're getting
real close to being a millionaire if
you're not
i'm trying and that's i've got
my christmas present from one of my
friends they bought me the baby steps
millionaire which i'm about to get
awesome
on your pre-shipment well thank you yeah
okay so i think the only thing you need
to do is probably a little bit of polish
a little bit of tuna
this feels disjointed in your
mind these things are kind of just a
patchwork of things rather than
it's like everybody's playing their own
instrument and you aren't leading the
orchestra
exactly that's the way it feels when you
presented it to me
um and so i i think you need to kind of
get these ducks to line up and waddle
together get them get them or fly
together or whatever metaphor we want to
destroy here but um
and let's try to get this thing
uh like you know let's dial these cabins
in and make them to making money or
stop it and sell them one let's look at
these stocks and go can we move that 200
000 or so or maybe more into some good
mutual funds with a smart vester pro
that can create some income okay that'll
create some income as well and i think
you pretty easily you're gonna have a
hundred thousand dollar your income to
work with
uh to enjoy your retirement number one
but number two to continue to invest and
do some other things with as you go
along i think you've done a better job
than you feel like you have
and the i think most of your most of
your lack of confidence is just the
the lack of a coordinated overall effort
versus each one of these independent
things as i look at them they all look
pretty good
i'd move the stocks but the cabins you
know i'll probably probably manage them
a little tighter a little tougher
make them make them cough some cash
rather than just dump it all back in
every time
and um
you know you got a lot in savings
probably too much unless you're getting
ready to buy something with some of it
and uh
you know you got that little seven to
ten acre piece of land what's the plan
with that if it's just to sit on it fine
but is that because it's going up in
value is this an investment is this
something you bought and you never got
rid of
so you kind of get kind of need to go
through these things line by line and go
okay
are they serving my retirement
or are they draining my retirement and
and i think with smart investor pro you
sit down with them can help you get a
lot of that done
something i've noticed in my life dave
my
mood or things going on in my life
affect when i sit down and look at
something
so what i'm hearing here also that i
want her to be aware of is when you
leave a job of 36 years even if you
loved it there's just a sense of
grieving like your life's going to be
different now what's it going to look
like and there's this there's it can be
that hollow feeling and then you sit
down and look at your retirement it just
feels like so much and it's all over
man she's doing a great job you've done
it you've done a wonderful job 36 years
as a teacher and you're a millionaire
yeah man we're really close by the way
the third
largest group of careers number three
most likely to be a millionaire career
list is teacher yeah
so take take some time and grieve the
fact you're not teaching anymore you
miss the camaraderie you're probably not
gonna miss all those meetings with the
parents and all the drama but you're
gonna miss some of that stuff miss some
of the kids and
don't miss most of the parents and then
make a great plan for what's next you're
halfway home you're halfway home
have some fun really done a good job
really done a good job let's just get
these ducks in a row and make them make
them fly the way you need them to fly to
get your goals your current set of goals
hit
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
exciting day today here at ramsey lots
of things going on around here we just
had christina ellis on last hour as our
newest ramsey personality joining the
crew
and uh the newest one on the air with me
anyway and
wonderful a wonderful young woman glad
to have her as a part of the team here
and you'll be hearing a lot more from
her particularly in the college loan
space she was featured in the
documentary we did about student loans
called borrowed future that has been a
big hit
also today is launch day the day that
baby steps millionaires has officially
gone on
sale in bookstores and online those of
you that have ordered it it's in the
mail on the way to you
and we appreciate the bazillion of you
that have bought one in advance thank
you for all your support thank you for
your confidence how ordinary people
built extraordinary wealth and how you
can too
on thursday night rachel cruz george
campbell and i will be doing a
an event called building wealth in 2022
over 100 000 people have already
registered for the free live stream the
1600 tickets in the room sold out very
very quickly but we'd love for you to
watch the live stream we're going to be
talking to you not only about the
current state of affairs with nfts and
bitcoin and
all the different things and nothing
down real estate that are booming out
there right now there's a huge get-rich
movement out there and wealth-building
movement out there and we're also going
to talk to you about what real people
have done that have caused them to
really build wealth
not mythology
and
so things that are that can be proven
with data and things that can be proven
uh with experience and with stories so
you're gonna enjoy this thursday night
the 13th at 7 p.m central time uh the
easiest way to uh the best way to view
it is to go to ramseysolutions.com
wealth you'll be able to watch it there
after you register
or
we'll hook you up with a link and you
can watch it at facebook or at youtube
wherever you want to do that but we'll
set you up with all of that if you
pre-register it is completely
free
ramsey solutions.com
wealth luke is with us in tulsa oklahoma
hey luke welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave hey john i appreciate all you
guys to do sure what's up
hey congrats on the new book thank you
all right yeah so so i uh i bought a
first home about
nine or ten years ago it's uh it's been
a rental for about seven years and i
just paid it off two days ago wow good
so thank you um
i i have a mortgage on a home now and
i'm wondering if you have any guidelines
when to keep it or to sell it to knock
off
knock off some on my primary just just
wondering your thoughts what do you owe
on your primary
we owe about 420 and what's your
household income
it's about 275.
oh wow excellent and what do you what's
this rental worth
uh about two maybe a little more okay
good for you
well um so so i mean the one option is
to sell the rental and throw it at the
420 making it 220.
but looking at the ratio of your income
275 to that 420
i see you paying off this house in what
three maybe four years
yeah i was a little i was a little
higher but somewhere around there yeah
we got we got private school and things
like that but uh i can do it in four i
think yeah if you're going to crank it
out to 10 i'd sell the rental
okay if you're going to go ahead and
knock it out in three or four
or whatever something like that
then um then i'm probably going to keep
the rental that's assuming you like the
rental and i kind of think you do
yeah it's it's great it's easy easy
money uh you know paid off so
uh yeah i do like the rental yeah
it's a pure cash flow
so
if you if i looked at these numbers and
it was going to be 10 years i would tell
you to sell the rental
gotcha even if you liked it but the fact
that you've got this big shovel to knock
this hole out pretty quick uh allows me
to go ahead and knock it out you know
move that direction kelly is with us in
monroe michigan hey kelly welcome to the
ramsey show
hi guys thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
um i need to pick your brain on mine and
my husband's vehicles
he works for one of the big three
automakers um and one of the benefits of
his level in the company is that we
drive two company cars there's insurance
and maintenance included
but there's still a payment that comes
out of my husband's check at the end of
the month it's not much um
yeah it's a thousand seventy one dollars
for two brand new cars yeah but this
includes it includes insurance it
includes depreciation
um it includes it's basically a lease
plan an employee benefit lease plan
right okay does it include does it
include fuel too
no i wish that'd be nice okay but it
doesn't include maintenance some of them
do
yes yes it does yeah you can't touch
this you this is a great deal
yeah okay it's a fabulous deal you can't
drive those cars or our car half that
expensive for what you're spending
you're spending 12 000 a year
yeah you add up the insurance and add up
the maintenance alone
okay
and and even if you want cars half that
expensive and you're getting the benefit
of driving brand new cars this is not a
car lease from a car dealer this is an
employee benefit i've looked at i've
looked at these numbers
yeah i've looked at these numbers many
many times we've got nissan in our
community they have a similar thing that
is absolutely incredible but i've looked
at the big threes they're up there too
and you guys i mean i think you may even
have a better deal than the nissan folks
have got
it's it's a bar it's a bargain though
you can't operate a vehicle for that i
mean i drive a a ford raptor right
that's what a i don't know maxed out
roush whatever 70 80 000 truck right i
can't operate that thing in depreciation
how much it loses in value
in insurance and in maintenance i can't
operate it for what you're doing two
cars
okay okay it's a deal
and these are nice cars too you got good
cars these aren't little you're not got
the bottom of the line you got the big
dogs
yes
you want to tell me who it is
uh chrysler oh okay
so what are you driving
have a wrangler my husband drives a ramp
1500
yeah okay
i rest my case yeah
that just tells me i was completely
right i thought i was right but that
nails it yeah yeah those are great cars
too
uh and what a great what a great benefit
for working for a big company like that
it's very cool uh i'm just thinking i
think you should kick one of those up
here at the office dave
we don't make cars here john that's well
played
there's that part
we do have deals on counseling with john
delonte
[Music]
unlimited unlimited
unlimited
and i'll help you with your budget i'm
trying and it's worth every dollar i'm
trying guys i'm trying yeah he's working
it but it's um no that sounds like an
incredible i'm just thinking about what
i'm paying car insurance every year
right i mean well yeah yeah you can't 12
000
i mean for two cars yeah that you
you probably can't buy the insurance not
on those cars because those are
expensive i mean that's that's they're
driving a hundred thousand dollars plus
worth of cars
and uh and they're doing it for a
thousand bucks a month so that that's
that is not folks boys and girls that is
not a car lease that you get at the
dealer this is an employee benefit
and it is a
phenomenal benefit it's a great one yeah
especially if you want to drive a nice
car yeah you know so there you go
um if you want to drive a hooptie maybe
not but it's a pretty good deal pretty
good deal open phones here at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
by the way let's just hit that as a
drive by just in case some of you are
new the car fleece i call it a fleece
because it's a bad idea right you're
getting sheep fleeced here um that was
bad but i do it all the time
it's like a dad joke i've been doing it
for 20 years right
i've been doing it for 20 years so um
but the you know when you add up what a
lease is costing you
and there's a way to put it in a
financial calculator the residual value
at the end of the lease which you can
buy the car for plus your payments as
opposed to the uh
manufacturer's suggested retail price
sticker which is what the lease is
calculated on
and you back out you can actually figure
out what you are paying for the money
in the lease world you're renting this
so it's not technically an interest rate
it's called cost of capital but the
effective interest rate on the average
car lease in america today is 14.2
percent
leasing sucks
don't do it
just i want to make sure we weave that
into this whole conversation of there
that was better wonderful and the goat
noise that was good even better but
there's a sheep
goats don't get fleeced farm boy
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
[Applause]
on the phone randall and krishna are
with us in sacramento california says on
my screen you guys are debt free
congratulations
oh thank you dave thank you feels so
good
love it love it love it
well done how much did you pay off
we paid off 95 000
i love it how long did this take
26 months
say again
26 months okay 26 months and your range
of income during that 26 months
we started at 100 000 went up to 140
and went down to 120.
very cool good job you guys absolutely
amazing so what kind of debt is the uh
was the 95 000
well dave it was mostly in student loans
we had about five thousand dollars in
credit cards which we knocked out in the
first month
and the rest of it was student loans
wow good for you how long you guys have
been married
well we actually got married throughout
the process uh we found out about the
baby's death in june of 2019
and
one of the things you preach is you
can't be playing house so we got married
in october
all right good for you guys
very cool i love it love it
so you dive in
and how did you connect up with us
yeah so actually my brother was the one
who connected us um
funny story we had a trip planned to go
to mexico to visit my wife my soon-to-be
wife to family
to get their blessings and everything
and it was just a few months before that
that we were introduced to you by my
brother
and right before we left on the trip we
really contemplated whether or not we
should actually go on this trip instead
just you know start on this debt-free
journey at that point
but we did uh decide to go on our trip
and we just hit it right off as soon as
we got back from um from that trip okay
so you go and get
her family's blessing
to get married and come home and it's
game on get out of debt
exactly like it good for you okay and 26
months later boom boom you're done
absolutely yes we also had the
opportunity to meet you at at the smart
conference people before kobe hit you
were here in sacramento and uh we went
to do our um
just to get motivated by everyone around
us oh very fun
good good well smart conference is a
good way to do that i can't wait to get
those going again
uh it's a it's a blast they're one of my
favorite conferences that we do
a a day long where we touch every area
of your life so good stuff 95 000 what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is
i would say commitment um
you know just sometimes we would fall
off the wagon and overspend at the
grocery store but go back and revisit
the budget and um you know just be
forgiving and start over
um and at the end it was like oh we
gotta stay on in the budget we gotta
stay in the budget so just you know that
commitment to it i think uh
the every dollar app is you know
something that we look at every hour
so
so yeah the same commitment thank you
what was the hardest thing you two went
through in your marriage this is hard
uh culturally it's hard like making this
commitment every month one of you
overspends the other one's just gritting
their teeth because they just understand
how did y'all manage this together
yeah so um
you know i think the hardest part is as
many people would say is telling people
no you know we live in a society where
oh it's the weekend let's go out to eat
at a restaurant oh let's let's go out
and do this oh let's go out and do that
and you know
unfortunately we've gotten to the point
where you know everything that people
want to do revolves around spending
money spending money spending money
and so when you're on this journey and
you know you constantly have to tell
people no you constantly have to tell
people why you're you're
you know you're telling them no it's
it's sometimes difficult to keep saying
that but you know we had each other we
knew that we were doing this for a
purpose and now you know thankfully
we can start telling people yes and do
all these things that we've been missing
out on for these past couple of years
yes and something that we got to mention
is that we had a baby along the way as
well he's turning one this month
incredible congratulations hey
yes life is good yeah we're seeing the
pics on
on youtube beautiful beautiful and i
also have a daughter
and she's in middle school in high
school i'm sorry and just having to say
no to her as well you know they are um
why you work so hard but having to say
no to her and and not doing all the fun
stuff that other kids her age get to do
uh what's a small sacrifice for a bigger
a bigger picture it was whole it was a
whole 26 months
it wasn't for 26 years
you tried telling a teenage girl
i know i know
i know i i'm just reminding you that you
did the right thing congratulations good
work well done well done well done you
guys are free congratulations how's it
feel
feels amazing um you know i always told
my told him my husband if we can do this
we can do anything now like seriously
now that we are out of debt and we have
all this money coming in it's just like
oh we have all this money we could just
buy a car cash in three months like wow
this is amazing so it's very well done
and very excited that's amazing yes yes
yes yes you got it you're on the way
well we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that's definitely
the next chapter in your story that's
the way things are going and the
direction you're going it's just
absolutely incredible so uh
we listen to you every single day thank
you so much well thank you we're honored
and uh we're proud of you guys you've
done incredible your heroes also got a
copy of total money makeover to uh get
you going and let you give that to
someone else and disrupt their lives and
get them moving in this direction so
that's what we're all about around here
stirring up a holy ruckus so uh you guys
are incredible well done well done well
done all right randall and kershner
sacramento california
95 000 paid off in 26 months making 100
to 140 to 120 count it down let's hear a
debt free scream
three two one we're that freeze
yes
[Applause]
so cool well done you guys
very very well done proud of you alec is
with us in raleigh north carolina hey
alec what's up
how much man how are you doing today
better than i deserve how can we help
love to hear it man um well my question
is is coming into next year i'm a young
guy i felt like i was doing really well
financially for someone my age and then
i've made some bad decisions some
uncontrollables happen so i have more of
like a mindset question how can i like
regain my confidence in building wealth
and you know kind of moving forward
because last year was a tough year for
me i made some bad decisions and i just
want to make sure i get back on the
right track kind of bad decisions yeah
well
i'm very spiritual and
i used to run a psychic business i got
very aggressive with investing in my
business
um because i wanted to make sure it was
flourishing and also i have a lot of
mental health issues and i felt like my
mental health was hurting my job
performance so i got pretty aggressive
at investing in my mental health trying
to fix my anxiety so i could perform
better in the workplace
so you just where was the mistake yeah
there's no mistake taking care of your
mental health did you put too much money
in your business and then it went belly
up yeah so basically with my business i
sold a lot of my stocks to invest in my
business i hired some business coaches
some other things and then as far as my
mental health i also hired some more
holistic um people there as well and i
put a lot of that in my credit card
and then also i had some like legal
issues with my old company that kind of
cost me some money that i ended up
having to put on my credit card as well
so how much credit card debt have you
got now
so i have six thousand dollars worth of
credit card debt and eight thousand
dollars worth of student loans yeah so
one of the things we believe around here
is the windshield's bigger than the rear
view mirror and that's called grace
you check the rear view mirror to figure
out what you did wrong
so that you don't do it again and your
core use that to course correct and you
stay
looking forward you need to have a
clearly defined goal of where you're
going
and you learn from your mistakes and
move on that's the mindset change we all
do it and that's the beauty of a new
year you get that fresh start
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day ephesians 1 18
i pray that the eyes of your heart may
be enlightened
in order that you may know the hope to
which he has called you the riches of
his glorious inheritance and his holy
people
winston churchill said all the great
things are simple
and many can be expressed in a single
word
freedom
justice
honor
duty
mercy
hope
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
david is in pittsburgh hi david welcome
to the ramsay show
hi dave hi dr john
what's up good to see you man
hey hey guys so
i have quite the situation right now um
i am uh 253 000 in debt in student loans
and i have a
uh two car loans that i'm paying off
right now and just trying to figure out
what i need to do
are you a doctor
i am a pharmacist pharmacist okay what
do you make
uh
our household income me and my wife is
two hundred thousand okay
and what do you owe on these cars
well my wife's car is she is thirty five
thousand and my car is seventeen
thousand okay all right
and um so you make what 100 and a
quarter she makes 75.
a little bit more than that i make about
uh 150 and she makes about 50. okay cool
how much do you own your house
uh i don't have a house we uh actually
brett how long have you been out of
school
uh six years
okay
all right
are you
ready to do what it takes to get out of
this mess
we are we both are actually i should say
um we have our first financial peace uh
class on
this sunday
good awesome good for you
okay because here's the good news you
make good money you have a good shovel
the bad news is you're in a deep hole
if you call me up and said you were in
this hole and you made a hundred
thousand dollars a year it's a lot more
bleak than if you make 200 a year
follow me
yes sir
and you've got good you're in a good
career field i don't know what does she
do
she is a nurse for a orthopedic surgeon
wonderful awesome okay
so the great news is both of you have
wonderful extra job opportunities
um
er or whatever
to pick up some ridiculous hours for a
short period of time and you probably
could get close to doubling your income
but you'd be working like absolute
maniacs for a short period of time the
good news if you did that is you could
be out of debt in a year and a half
depending on how maniac you get
if you just try to do it with 200
it's gonna take you four years and
you're gonna have to sell her car
yes sir
are you ready
we're in we're we're going for this so
it may mean that she's got she's got a
nursing job for a surgeon she probably
likes the guys or the man or woman she
works for it's a good setup it may mean
that she goes and gets a contract job
and doubles her income fifty thousand
dollars for a nurse is pretty low and
she goes full time
and also does weekend stuff too are you
ready
i'm ready i'm ready to do whatever i
don't know you're shifting on me are you
all ready she's not uh well i should
throw one thing out there we have a baby
we have a two-year-old and we also have
a baby on the way so do you want that's
awesome do you want a then man you hit
the gas do you want a a six-year-old who
is still sitting with struggling parents
or do you want a four-year-old who has
no idea what debt is
that's the choice it's going to hurt
either way i want my heart to be over
quicker
well i don't think uh pregnant mama's
gonna be working weekend shifts in the
er so that is though
but dude you are you're working all the
time
you're going to be a ghost we need a
bunch of calls today i'm ready to go
good i like it and we're and we are
selling her car yeah you got to sell her
car
yes sir it's ridiculous yeah and uh and
you already knew it didn't you
i oh absolutely i know the baby stuff
does she know it
um yeah she is beginning to know it um
she is fairly new to it but she is in
with us well here here's the thing there
is a direct ratio and you can just
discuss it with her logically this is
not about you using dave ramsey as a
weapon on your wife or john deloney or
anything like that that's not what we're
talking about but it's a simple math
equation darling
the deeper we sacrifice
the faster we're out
and the higher the probability is that
we ever get out
so you're g
you raise the
intensity and the raise the passion
level and the belief level that you both
have to the highest possible level and
cut to the deepest possible core
and the cut is spending
and the cut is uh you're not gonna be
home you're gonna be working all the
time
any pharmacy gig you can get anywhere
whether it's hospital er on the weekends
i don't know wherever it is you can use
this degree to make the most money in
the shortest period of time you don't
want to do it for long
but i am telling you for two years if
you'll go bananas you can be free
yes
and uh that's that's worth doing at your
age especially live like no one else so
that later you can live and give like no
one else now what i would do is i don't
think you get off the phone and you
march in and say dave said sell your car
that's probably bad strategy would you
agree
absolutely so i think you guys go ahead
and go to the financial peace university
class and you start talking and a good
way to have these conversations is ask a
lot of questions
what could we cut what could we do that
would get us there the fastest possible
way because the faster we get there
the more peace we're gonna have the more
time we're gonna have with our family
the more money we're gonna have later
the faster we get there the faster we
get to freedom
because uh you know a lot of people in
your situation you've already drug this
out six years half ass doing it
absolutely and you got to get you just
got to get gang on man
and i want to tell you this i i had
i didn't have as much student loans you
did but me and my wife had six figures
between us and so when i look at the
income ratio the ratio is very similar
and i had a two-year-old little boy and
i had a lot of guilt about how much
extra work i was taking on and how much
i was going
let me just tell you what years 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 and 11 with no debt with that kid
has been like very very different
very very different
suck it up have a hard 18 months 24
months to get this stuff done
get it done man
the strange thing is john um and for
those of you guys listening out there
you're listening to these numbers okay
two hundred thousand dollar income 253
000 student loans 35 on one car 17 on
the other car about three hundred
thousand dollars a debt yeah and making
200 but the ability to
uh
you know put another uh 100 on there
legitimately and even more later if
needed with her kicking in absolutely um
that's something to consider but the
weird thing is
the stuff
because it's an intensity passion-based
thing
that drives the sacrifice
it's not
a uh
a straight line it's on a curve
the effect is on a curve
meaning that if you do 50 of what i'm
talking about in terms of intensity it
does not give you 50 results it gives
you 35 results
but if you do 80 of what i'm talking
about it's not going to give you
uh it's going to it's going to tip the
scales over the other way and you're
going to you know when you're just going
bonkers you see these people and
everything starts to it's like a
magnetic pull it starts to move towards
the goal everything in their life starts
to form up and move into it but you
don't get that kind of um
that kind of draw power that kind of
suction so to speak on it attraction so
to speak on it uh without creating this
tremendous
speed and effort and intensity and force
if you come back 50 percent all of a
sudden your your return on that's 25
it's not you can't you can't do it right
in the middle right in the middle
doesn't give you middle results it gives
you horrible results that's exactly
right and that's how you get nowhere in
six years that's right was with that
problem right there so that's why when
you we say gazelle intense it works and
you go bananas and it pushes through
that is the deal that's right good stuff
dr john deloney ramsey personality my
co-host ben and kelly in the booth james
making this happen thank you guys i am
dave ramsey your host will be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
you